my life is a chip in your pile ante up
[Music]
so this is something that I've kind of
wanted to go on our long ramble about
for a really long time but I haven't had
context with which to do it because I
don't really talk about video games here
I've done one of her video game related
entry in this entire channel and that
was it many many many many many many
years ago but you know what it's my
channel I'm gonna talk about what I want
so consider this to be a new occasional
series because it granted before it led
to something more but I did why Gotham
is awesome so this will be the second
entry in why it's awesome so this will
be an occasional you know something that
I do just to ramble about something that
I really love that I don't have to some
other context to talk about
it'll be uploaded sporadically like
nitpick rants in that way but I want to
talk about my favorite video game of all
time Final Fantasy 6
I knew it is Final Fantasy 3 back when I
played it on the Super Nintendo in fact
I still have it in the box at that I
just thing of beauty
so I have played this specific cartridge
probably all the way through to
completion three times I have played it
to completion when it was released on
the ps1 I played it through to
completion when it was released on the
Game Boy Advance I would say all that
all things told I probably sunk between
two and three hundred hours into this
game and now I'm just gonna rant at you
about all the reasons why it's amazing
let's start with story because that's
the true heart of any RPG especially the
16-bit era of our PGs they weren't big
showy technical kind of things although
some of them could look very pretty in
very certain ways but it was all it was
all about the story that's why you were
there now I did mention the one other
video game video I have up here and that
was
me kind of tearing the Final Fantasy
seven which is a very good game but I
noted in that video and I'll reiterate
here because I don't expect anyone to go
that far back into my channel that Final
Fantasy seven began the tradition of
very over complicated stories with
bizarre twists that don't really make
sense in them being kind of a Final
Fantasy staple Final Fantasy 6 predates
that and it is a wonderfully
straightforward story in fact almost
simplicity to the point that you would
think it would be dull because you have
an oppressive Empire you have a group of
resistance fighters those are the
characters you control go and if that
sounds generic and the broad strokes it
is but it's down to the fine details
it's down first of all to the characters
this is a phenomenal cast of characters
but I'll be getting into more more into
them later but it's also just the way
that the story unfolds over time and the
way that the story is told not so much
that the actual plot and synopsis of it
is particularly original and I'll tell
you what I mean when I first fired up
this game I got sucked in very early on
so when the game opens we get a bit of
text it doesn't layout Empire evil
returners which is the resistance group
good instead it gives us background war
of the Magi magic was destructive magic
hasn't been seen in a long time we're in
an age of technology but magic might be
coming back and that's dangerous that's
the context we're given and then we get
our initial three characters that we
control that's VIX wedge and Terra
should have been Biggs and actually I
think in later versions after the SNES
they did fix that because it was
supposed to be a Star Wars reference but
in the original version it was Vic so
that's what's in my head
so you take the three of them and you
head into this town where an esper has
been discovered and Esper being a
believed extinct kind of magical
creature so first of all it's this slow
pacing of these these characters in this
magical
of an armored you know basically Amex
suit walking across the snow in the mode
7 graphics as this gorgeous music I'll
be talking about the music some more
again later to plays and the opening
credits roll and it it is cinematic it's
not how video games started not back in
1994 but then you get there and you get
into what is usually the big slog of any
RPG which is the tutorial section where
the game has to climb at you - you know
how the combat works the different
options how you manage your character's
inventory and I and all that stuff and
it's almost always a slog in every RPG
because you just they have to give you
these little rinky-dink challenges
generally they put the story on hold or
actually many times they won't really
allow the story to start until they've
gotten the tutorial izing done and out
of the way so here you get into this
town and again these are the characters
you control so media assume oh I'm
controlling the good guys so you get
into the town and you are attacked you
the the town marshals whatever they
attack you first and you wipe the floor
with a piece of cake so you're learning
the combat mechanics in combat and
fights that aren't actually much of a
threat to you not particularly atypical
but stick with me so you get there you
get to the Esper you get one boss fight
through you and the guys basically got
one trick up his sleeve that you deal
with all okay cool so I know to pay
attention to certain things awesome but
then you get to the Esper and vixen
wedge gone Tara the one who remains gets
recovered and now you start to get more
information that you actually just
played your tutorial section playing the
bad guys Tara was undermined control but
the other two were just soldiers of the
empire and not only were you playing the
bad guys but those those sort of magitek
armor that you are wearing that's gone
so now you get out into the mines trying
to escape and you're now
fighting the exact same things that you
were just slapping around left and right
with your magitek armor without that
armor which means that fights that were
a piece of cake for you a man ago now
become harder and you have to pay
attention to and it's completely organic
it is a wonderful mix of how the
gameplay helps and enhances the story
rather than the story got put on hold so
we could give you a tutorial section and
the more that you think about as you get
out you go oh crap not only was I
playing as the bad guys but I had all
that technology that means that's what I
have to try and fight it immediately
establishes the power and strength of
the Empire it gives you all the tutorial
izing you need and then bumps you down
to a lower level that feels organic and
doesn't make you feel nerfed it makes
sense within the story and the entire
game is littered with moments like that
we're storytelling in game play meet so
even though the broad strokes of
assemble your party get a resistance
group take on the Empire is really
generic and the broad strokes the
various execution of various points of
that story is just done so well and I
mentioned the characters this thing has
a big cast there are 14 playable
characters in this thing 12 main ones
and two bonus characters well I say
bonus Neil optional they come in way
late in the game and they're not
plotting necessary but all the other 12
you encounter them as the story goes
along and they're all great characters
I'll talk about how they play a little
bit later but right now let's just talk
characterization this is probably my
favorite group of characters in a Final
Fantasy game because despite there being
12 of them nobody feels redundant
everybody's unique and yet nobody feels
like they were brought in from another
game cuz I mean let's be honest you play
Final Fantasy 7
kate's it feels like he's from another
game compared to the rest of these guys
you play Final Fantasy 9 you look at
Quinn and go really alternately you play
something like Final Fantasy 8 and
they're all interchangeable they're all
the same age with the same history in
the same background here every single
one of these characters has a unique
story a unique perspective a unique
and I have reason to love every single
one of these characters I think I'm
probably partial to lock myself but that
the this entire cast is phenomenal
and then there's the look the visual
aesthetic I adore the artwork of
yoshitaka amano and even though he has
continued to do promotional artwork for
the Final Fantasy series from this this
was the last game where he actually did
the character and some of the monster
design himself he didn't take do
somebody else's design and do his spin
on it from the peroneal he was doing the
art initially and I love this guy's art
so much and it is so perfectly captured
in the portrait images of the characters
when you go to your your main menu
screen and in the command the monsters
now to me this was actually the first
Final Fantasy game that I sat down to
play but I was aware of Final Fantasy
before this because I had a subscription
to Nintendo Power I actually got all
those still sitting around in a box
somewhere but I kind of knew fanta final
fantasy in my head as the game with the
really cool monster sprites because I
would look at those and go it's really
neat and I remember even I think it was
actually an article they did on Final
Fantasy legend for the Game Boy but
there was this piece of art that was a
Yoshi talked to Amano piece of art this
huge intimidating character just like
holding that little I think it was a
city in his hand as this does this
desert drain through his fingers you
snarling I'm looking at going I don't
know what this is I don't know if I'll
ever play it but man that's gorgeous and
I think this game really captures the
spirit of his artwork so well of course
I'd be remiss if I didn't talk about the
music and circle back on that again oh
man Nobuo Uematsu is he's a legend a
video game composition and rightfully so
I own the soundtracks of a number of
games that he did music for including
some of the other Final Fantasy games
this is my favorite soundtrack that he
did and not for the reason that most
people are gonna say oh the Opera I like
the Opera I don't consider it as much of
a seminal
as a lot of people seem to for some
reason what I love about the music is
every single character has their own
theme music now that's not actually a
typical for Final Fantasy but remember
there's 14 of them
plus there's unique themes for two of
the villains for emperor gestahl and for
Kefka and whatever information you
didn't get about these characters just
based off their sprite or their portrait
images you get the remainder information
just by how their soundtrack sounds
Locke has this bold adventuring kind of
track terra has a much more melancholy
track reflecting the fact that she's
trying to figure out who she is and
she's she's on a very she's very much a
journey it's the traveling music
Selassie's track has a sense of longing
to it stray goes just kind of sounds old
and crotchety
MOG gets the goofy track because hey
he's a mughal and on and on and on and
it's just oh my god the music is so good
and not only does every character have
their own unique track although it just
occurred to me and if i don't say that
somebody will point it out in the
comments yes edgert 7 have the same
track because they're brothers i know
that let's move on if it's an important
location it gets its own track as well
even incidental background characters
like Rachel for Locke's background story
she gets her own track if thats gorgeous
too now let's talk a little bit more
about the gameplay because you know any
game can have a great story even great
characters if it's not fun to play it
doesn't matter it's a slog and you're
not going to enjoy it this game is so
much fun to play first of all the combat
you are in and out of it so quick
because it just zoom right into it you
fight and you're done it doesn't do the
thing that they've started doing ever
since Final Fantasy 1 3d which is you
know you we're in the fight who now
we're gonna pan around so you can see
every angle on this character and you
know your characters visit like know
you're fighting go go go go done move on
so it helps battle the fact that the
game probably could feel a little bit
grindy I honestly never felt that it did
but the combat is so quick that does a
lot to alleviate any possible grinding
you might be feeling there's also a
surprising amount of nuance to the
combat but more than that to the
characters because this is another thing
that I love about these characters
besides you know great characterization
story look all of that what I really
love about these characters is within
the function of the game every single
one of them is useful and yes every
single one
there is no superfluous there is no
point there is no thing this character
is good at character they don't exist
how many games with a sizeable party can
claim that much less one with 14
playable characters and before you argue
with me I'm not gonna go through point
for a point for every character but let
me make a couple things clear
not every character is useful throughout
the entire game some characters are
gonna be super useful when you first get
them edgar is a great example of that
his tools things like the auto crossbow
the noise blaster the drill they are
gonna be your go-to things for a long
time but then other characters surpass
him so he doesn't stand out as much
later on but he had his moment to shine
ditto with cyan in that respect cuz his
early stuff is really good at the time
you get him there were some that are
good pretty much the whole time you have
them saben is a good example of that
some don't get their proper potential
too little bit later like Terra some
characters are fairly situational but
you marrow really good to have it the
fanatics tower gogo with his many thing
he gotta time it right but you do it
right works really well some characters
take a bit of time to get to work cow
that's a bit of a grinding character but
if you're willing to sync the time into
him he's a powerhouse even the
characters you might think are useless
are actually quite good if you know what
you're doing because now every character
is their only unique ability but here's
the thing not everybody's unique ability
is great now every character can learn
magic every character can actually learn
every spell in the game but if you pay
attention to their stats you realize who
should actually be using what and who
should be doing magic as opposed to
doing you know just the melee fighting
and things like or sticking to whatever
there's special talent is so let's take
realm
one of the more maligned characters
because her unique ability is kind of
used
it even has an upgraded version that is
only slightly less useless but if you
pay attention then you will notice that
she has the highest magic text at base
level in the game so one of the fun
things about this game as you level up
and the way you learn magic is you equip
different Esper's so that you can learn
their spells but also if you have them
equipped at the point that you level up
you will get a boost to certain stats
depending on who you have equipped at
the time so if you want and you want to
kind of have everybody the same you can
use that to boost stats that maybe
they're weak on you know give somebody
some extra hip points bring their
defense up or if you're like me and you
like to lean into a character skill you
boost the heck out of what they're
already good at and make them a monster
at it you boost a realm on her attacks
on her magic attack skill which she's
already got the best starting based stat
in the game yeah she will be your go-to
match you know user and she will destroy
everything my favorite discovery though
for figuring out how a character that I
was like I can't figure out what this
guy's good for Setzer now Setzer special
skill is this sort of slot machine thing
and it's something that's been reused
since then kate's have had it in Final
Fantasy 7 now again keep in mind I've
sunk somewhere between two and three
hundred hours into this thing there were
combinations on that slot machine I have
never ever seen that I don't know what
the percentage on the random number
generator is I just have to assume that
no one's actually ever seen them so
forget that but here's the thing there's
a relic and relics are most relics can
be used by most characters some can only
use specific ones this is actually one
that anyone can use there's a relic
called the offering now what the
offering lets you do is whenever you
choose the attack option you hit four
times instead of one initially sounds
great awesome but when you actually
start using it what you realize quickly
is you're not really doing more damage
your character is simply taking the
damage that would have been done in one
hit and splitting it across four hits
instead and if there's multiple and
he's on the screen it he might jump he
or she might jump between them you know
hit this one for to hit that one for one
then then the one in the middle for one
and because he can't really control that
and it's a little bit random who gets
the hits yeah it doesn't seem that
useful anymore but there are certain
weapons that because the nature of what
is determining the attack value of that
weapon is separate from the normal stats
that most weapons use
they are kind of exceptions to that rule
and the offering doesn't split up their
damage the same way there's like I said
there's a couple of weapons that do that
one of them is a weapon exclusive to
Setzer it's called the loaded dice now
the loaded dice is a randomized weapon
he throws dice and depending on what you
roll you will do damage now you were all
on the high end of that he is capable of
doing now 9999 points of damage that is
the most you can hit for in the game of
course it's a roll maybe you hit for
nothing but you know what that role is
not split apart by offering every at
time he attacks with offering it's a
fresh roll which means you equip him
with the loaded dice and the offering he
rolls four times I guarantee you at
least one of those is gonna hit for
8,000 plus damage if you're lucky he
might even do that twice so like I said
every single character has use some of
them you need to kind of dig into to
figure out what it could be
some of them you do need to do some
specific building and working with them
strago gow but everyone has used there
is no useless character in this game now
some of the things I just mentioned if
you know how to take advantage of them
like how powerful realm gifts with their
magic how powerful Setzer is when you
pair that weapon with that relic you
might think you're overpowered by the
end you're just burning through the game
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
the last dungeon of this thing and I'm
just gonna talk about this dungeon
design without getting into spoilers
because I'll talk about some more
spoilers stuff at the back end just in
case game is 24 years old and I'm
worried about spoilers whatever so the
last dungeon you can't just pick your
strongest group and power through the
thing you actually have to make
three parties of up to four characters
apiece now remember there are 12 lazy
characters and two bonus characters so
if you have everybody there's two you
can cycle out if you didn't get the
bonus characters you have to use every
single character whether you built them
up or not if you have not recovered
every character because of the way the
second half of the game works you might
even be short so now you've got a
balance and figure out okay fine so if I
put my strong magic attacker here and
get this lined up so the decent defense
I'll get a good melee fighter over here
I've got this one with the goods so
you've got a divvy it up across the
three you can't have any be the weak one
because they're all gonna have to deal
with some series stuff as they work
their way along their portion of the of
the last dungeon and then the last boss
is truly epic it is a tiered fight you
work your way up just this mountain of
insanity and trust me as overpowered as
you may have just thought I described
you will need every advantage you can
get cuz the final boss he has a move
that no matter what you've got going out
for you will put you at one health and
you will be scrambling to face whatever
carriage as you can before he starts
wiping you out by just flicking snot at
you and so now I want to get into some
of the stuff that would constitute
spoilers some of the latter half story
turns that a little bit more about the
villain so if you have not played this
game yet if anything I have said has
convinced you to play this game go and
play the game in don't watch the rest of
this just know I'm just gonna keep
jabbering on about what's awesome about
this game so spoilers in three two one
alright so the heroes lose halfway
through the game the heroes lose your
goal is to prevent the Empire from
taking control of this floating comment
that will allow them to just make the
world as they see fit well you get there
and the Emperor who has been a
legitimate threat up to this point he's
working totally legit as a villain he
gets taken out by his lieutenant kefka
Oh Kefka in my mind best villain of the
Final Fantasy series not the coolest
villain Sephiroth gets that but kefka's
the best he's the most is so hateable as
a villain but so he decides he he very
much is the Joker of Final Fantasy and
15 years before Heath Ledger would say
it this guy he just wants to watch the
world burn
so Emperor Gestalt wants to rule the
world kefka just wants to mess it up for
fun so he kills Gaston and then
deliberately screws everything up and
the world effectively ends our heroes
are flung to the far corners of the
world numerous towns get destroyed the
world is literally reshaped everything
you were fighting to prevent happens and
then you start again in control of a
character that you have never had
individual control over up to this point
and you've got to try and pick up the
pieces and that's another thing about
the way the story unfolds there's no one
clear-cut central character there are
central characters to different segments
but there's no single hero of this story
most other Final Fantasy games there is
Final Fantasy 4 its Cecil 7 it's cloudy
8 its squall bends I Dane Titus they did
you've got a clear cut this is your main
character it's not the case here they
give you 12 characters all of them fully
developed and when you start in the
second half of the game you're
controlling Celeste who you've never
controlled by herself before unless you
want to count the Opera but all the
characters that you might have thought
oh that's who I'll start with because
that's who I started with in the
beginning like maybe Terra lock edgert
sabot even coalos your original 4 nope
no idea where they are
you've got so less I love that this game
does not have a clear central character
it makes the
since I brought him up let's talk about
Kefka now if I were to play Final
Fantasy 6 for the very first time now I
would probably call that he's got to end
up being in the final baddie at the end
of the game because the the recurring
repeated doesn't seem totally
trustworthy looks like a mid-boss but he
keeps coming back character kind of
taking over the story from who we
thought was gonna be the big villain I'm
not gonna go so far as to say it's
cliche but it happens enough that I
might have called it at the age of 12
playing it for the first time nah didn't
call it but he is just so wonderfully
hateable because that huh that laughs
that that 16-bit digitized laugh I
remember just before the floating
continent segment you've gone to bait
and you basically have just negotiated
peace between the Empire and the Esper's
like and even to the point that the
characters all kind of turned to the
camera do a wave like oh yes that's the
end and then you hear that laugh and you
just feel it in your gut like ah Shh and
as a final boss he looks great
he talks great his music is wonderfully
maddening he is a worthy final foe to
have to take down I love this guy's a
villain but after you beat him you get
what is my own personal favorite ending
of any video game ever all time and it's
not because there's some big twist that
happens it's not because there's a
gorgeous cinematic you sit back and
enjoy it's because it is satisfying in a
way that no other video game ending I've
ever seen is because it gives you every
single one of these characters get some
moment you get to hear their theme again
you get to see an image of something
that exemplifies them and then you get
to see them as you're all working to
know get out
this castle built by a madman that's
crumbling now that he's dead
you're all working to get out of there
they each have a moment to shine and it
varies some of them are funny some of
them are touching some of them are
tragic and it flows naturally from one
to the other
everyone has their moment and the music
swells and it builds and by the end when
they're back on that airship and it just
goes it is so triumphant and it is such
a climate and you're the credits are
rolling during this point bu you
wouldn't notice you're not noticing
these credits you're just sitting there
and then that airship sails off at the
very at the very end and it goes to
black and it ends and you just feel and
the music you just feel you so go it's
just so satisfying it is almost a half
hour long and it's riveting after
spending however many hours you choose
to sink into this game with these
characters who are also well realized so
well developed who have their own music
themes that you get to hear again as
part of this ending oh my god nothing
else has a has ever come close I
actually had an initial real big
disappointment with the ending to Final
Fantasy 7 not because it's bad but
because my standard was far away to c6
and I'm sorry nothing else comes close
never has I've played games that I love
I adore that wrap up in terrific ways
maybe some of which I'll even talk about
on future entries into this series but
I'll never have an ending that satisfies
the wave this ending satisfies and for
that and for so many other reasons Final
Fantasy 6 is my favorite video game of
all time so that's my long rambley I've
not I've now killed my voice just going
on and on about why Final Fantasy 6
is awesome I don't know what some of the
other things will be that I'll talk
about in this they'll probably get some
other video games in there I'll probably
get some movies that I really love and I
don't have occasion to talk about
otherwise we'll see what comes up but
Final Fantasy 6 have you played it what
do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it do all the
stuff like subscribe I've got Twitter
and email and podcast and I've got a
patreon links for all that stuff is down
below and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]